[MUSIC PLAYING]
HAEMIN SUNIM: When
I was a teenager,
I often wonder, why am I here.
I felt as though I was
just thrown into this world
without giving me any kind
of answer or guidance.
And some philosophers
describe this feeling
like waking up in
a movie theater
and then the movie has been
playing for the last 10
minutes.
So you are just
waking up and then try
to figure out what
this drama that we
are experiencing right now.
You are just thrown
into this movie theater.
So I was watching the drama
of my life as a teenager
and tried to figure it out.
What is that which is
watching this drama.
So I became very interested
in spiritual practices
and became very
interested in religion,
so I ended up studying
religion in college.
And then I was following
many different teachings,
but ultimately I wanted to
just experience, quote unquote,
enlightenment like
the way Buddha did.
So I said maybe I
should become a monastic
and get the proper
training, and maybe I'll
be able to have that experience.
So I became a monk after
my graduate school.
And then I went
through the training.
And while living in
Buddhist monastery,
I realized that while we are
meditating and all that--
however, every Sunday, we do
offer services for lay people--
however, after the
late in the services,
they will want to come and
have a conversation over tea
with Buddhist monks.
So what ended up happening
was I was sitting there
in my 20-something--
I was like mid-20 and then
having a deep conversation
with people over 40s, 50s, 60s.
They're telling me
about stress at work.
They have problem
with their children.
There are illness they
are going through.
Of course, I didn't have enough
life experience at that time.
All I could do was
just listen very
attentively and compassionately.
And the good thing was that that
really helped them apparently.
So what they really want
is somebody there rather
than giving them the
answer, they wanted somebody
to really listen.
And so I was getting
good at that actually,
and I realized
that that could be
part of my spiritual practice.
In Buddhism, you need two
things to become awaken.
First one is wisdom, and
another one is compassion.
And both side-- it is
absolutely necessary.
And I realized that maybe
I can cultivate compassion
by engaging with
everyday problems
that people are having and
offering whatever the wisdom
that I have.
So that led me to do a
little bit of social media.
In my opinion, I think the
social media is a tool just
like any other tool.
It can be used in
a positive way,
or it can be used
in a negative way.
So I start writing something
much more meditative
and helpful remarks that
came from my meditations
or helping other peoples.
And then that became really
popular in Korea first.
And then I was invited
to write a book.
At first, I didn't think
that my book will become
very popular to be honest.
But it became really popular.
It's called "The Things You Can
See Only When You Slow Down."
I think it was published here a
couple of years ago in London--
in the UK as well.
And then what
happened was I decided
to use whatever the
attention that I was
receiving for the public good.
So I began what is called
School of Broken Hearts.
So I set up four
years ago in Seoul
where people who are
going through a difficulty
in their lives, they can
come and they can share.
For example, if you are just
recently diagnosed with cancer
or if you just lost
your family member
or if you just went through
a very difficult divorce
or people who just got laid off,
all this difficult experience,
oftentimes we feel that we are
all alone, completely isolated,
and scared.
However, if you are--
if we come together,
then you will realize
that I'm not the only one,
and we can all do this together.
And especially if you
get to share your feeling
and through--
you can share through
language or through dance,
through writing, through
paintings, in different ways,
in a very supportive and caring
way and that can help you
tremendously I realized.
So the school has
grown quite a bit now,
and we have like 50 or 60
teacher working together.
And we have two
different center.
And they're from
that experience.
And as I was speaking
with more people
in the center and the
while giving a talk,
I was able to write
a second book, which
is "The Love for Imperfect
Things," and here I am.
SHIFALI MUDUMBA: Well, welcome.
We're very glad that you
wrote the second book.
So I actually want to touch
a little bit on your school
because when I read about that,
I thought about the skills
that we're taught at school.
We're taught everything
from ceramics
to woodwork to circuitry,
but this education system
doesn't really equip us
with everyday skills,
whether it's compassion
or self care.
What are your views on
life, and what can we do--
maybe there are people
here with children--
and how do we educate
ourselves on this journey.
HAEMIN SUNIM: Right.
I notice that unfortunately
the traditional school system,
they do not teach us how
to become more self aware--
become aware of who we are
and under what circumstances
I thrive and under
what circumstance
I don't do very well and what
kind of personality do I have
and what kind of path
do I want to walk along.
These are the very important
questions, and if we fail,
how can I pick myself up?
How can I get out of this?
When I feel so much anger,
how do we overcome it?
Or if I need to forgive somebody
or let it go, how do I do that?
All those important skill
that's directly related
to our life, everyday life, we
didn't learn it unfortunately.
So that's why I started the
School of Broken Hearts.
I think we as a human being,
we go through a difficulty
whether we like it or not
because we have a human body.
So we will get sick.
We get disappointed.
So in my school, I
invite many therapists
or wonderful teacher.
We do it together
to figure out things
that we didn't learn in
college or in high school.
SHIFALI MUDUMBA: So one
of the tenets of Buddhism
is life is suffering.
But when you look at the
world that we live in today,
I think it's fair to say that
everybody feels that life
is good or life is great.
How did we end up here,
and what do we do?
HAEMIN SUNIM: Whoa, very
philosophical question.
Very good.
Well, in Buddhism, life by
nature is not suffering.
When we are grasping, when
we are attaching ourselves
to a certain thing, whether
it's your idea, whether it's
your health, whether
it's your relationship,
and holding onto it in hoping
that this will not change,
then it creates suffering.
So what they are
saying is everything
that has form or shape is
inevitably will change.
It is impermanent.
So if you can truly see
that it is impermanent,
then you enjoy--
you can rejoice what you
have knowing that what
you are having is temporary.
So even if you are having
a wonderful life right now,
you may at some point get sick.
When you experience
that, then that
becomes a opportunity for
us to deepen compassion.
I am sick, and then
at that time you
get to realize that there
are a lot of people going
through many terrible
difficult illness,
for example, that
invite ourselves
to become more compassionate
and have open heart.
So I think difficulty in
our lives are great lessons.
It makes our spirit
to become more mature.
SHIFALI MUDUMBA: And how does
the compassion arise from that?
So how do we exercise
the compassion then?
HAEMIN SUNIM: So
let's say we are
in a very difficult situations.
And if we are completely lost
in that thoughts, feeling
of victim, I just
didn't want it.
It just happened to me.
I feel like a victim.
It's terrible.
And if we just keep on thinking
about ourselves only and not
really connecting to
the bodily emotions,
things that is
happening to you--
in other words, if you
just dwell on what happened
in the past and continually
regurgitate that thought over
and over again, then you
feel like you are a victim,
and you cannot get out of it.
However, if you begin
to turn that attention
to other people who are
in similar situations,
then you begin to see
that through the pain,
we actually connect.
We can actually
understand each other.
This is the part of the life.
And that makes us stronger
and allow us to break out
of our egotistic shell.
SHIFALI MUDUMBA: Talking
about imperfection
and perhaps there are times
when, especially in January,
it's very timely.
Everyone wants to be
skinnier, has a list of New
Year resolutions.
And in the book you talk about
your existence is enough.
But that's quite hard to embrace
when the world is telling us
that we could be better.
And how do we navigate this
because on the one hand,
we should be happy with our
existence, but on the other,
it can get confusing when
we all want to improve.
Like it's OK to have goals
and want to be better,
but where do you find the
balance between the two.
HAEMIN SUNIM: Hmmm, this is
another excellent question.
I think we are all
imperfect, right.
Would you agree?
Yeah.
Like and I think
it's good that we
recognize some of
our imperfection
and try to become better
at it, whatever that is.
There is nothing wrong with it.
However, just remind
ourselves-- can you
remember the last time when you
felt really peaceful and happy.
Can you remember that.
You could be when you are
in a vacation, somewhere
warm or a beautiful
mountain or in the company
of your good friends,
whenever that is.
In that time, what was the
overall quality of your mind?
Your mind at that
time was you were
appreciating that
particular present moment
that you are experiencing.
And there was no
resistance to what is.
Are accepting as it is.
You feel grateful for what is.
Am I right?
Yeah.
So likewise the happiness
that we are seeking
is actually accepting as it is.
If we can-- our heart become
serene and become peaceful
and there's more space for
us to embrace and become OK
with what is.
And, of course, if we find some
other problems in our life,
then what happened
is we are not content
with the present moment, so our
mind is automatically escape.
We think about the
future, and we regret
what happened in the past.
So while doing that, we are
missing out the present moment.
So let me just also talk
about one interesting thing.
When I first became a monk,
I had this idealized image
of a perfect monk.
So I was assigned to
master, my mentor,
and so I was hoping
that my mentor would
be this idealized perfect monk.
But when I first met
him, he wasn't anything
like what I had in mind.
My idealized monk is
very dedicated, serious,
meditate really hard,
and then imparts
very wisdom and all that.
But my mentor monk,
[? the ?] master, he was--
he loves to make jokes.
He also has some temper.
He gets angry.
So he wasn't exactly
what I had in mind.
And then at that time
what happened was I
had a close monk
friend, and we were
ordained around the same time.
So he invited me to his temple.
So I went to his
temple, and I had dinner
with him and his old master.
So when I first
met his master, he
was exactly what I had in mind.
He was here-- his mind was
serene and serious and meditate
a lot and imparts
in all the wisdom.
So I was thinking, oh,
gosh I wish I can switch.
I wish I can change my mentor.
So I was a little
envious of him.
And then 10 years passed, and
then I met my friend again out
on the street accidentally.
And then I was very
happy, of course.
I said, oh, it's
so nice to see you.
Long time no see.
How have you been, and how
is your perfect master?
And he said that, oh, well,
I am no longer in touch
with my master.
I was very shocked.
He's not having any kind
of contact with his master.
I say, why?
Your master is perfect.
And he said that
because he was perfect,
he demanded that all of his
disciples to be perfect, too.
So he reprimand people
if they are committing
something that is not correct.
So they were feeling really bad
about themselves all the time.
So he felt hurt, and so he left.
At that time I realized that
my master wasn't bad at all.
The fact that he
has a humor, it's
like a great quality I realize.
He doesn't take
himself very seriously,
and he knows that
he's imperfect.
Because he's imperfect--
he knows he's imperfect,
he's willing to forgive other
people who is imperfect.
So a lot of monks
who have some trouble
or have some scandal
outside, they
will all ended up
coming to my temple,
and we are all living happily
together because my master is
so forgiving anyway.
And whenever he gets angry, and
he I usually feel bad about it
next day, and he gives
me a pocket money.
So there are so many
wonderful qualities.
So I still get along
with my master very well,
and I really respect my master.
So I think once we
accept our imperfections,
I think we become much
more genuine person.
And we are willing to
show our vulnerability.
When we show our
vulnerable side,
then I think we can
meet on other people
in a much deeper and true way.
And that there you can create
much meaningful and deep
relationship.
SHIFALI MUDUMBA: You
speak about acceptance
and accepting our imperfections,
other people's imperfections,
and you speak about how
that starts with self care,
self-love.
So can you tell us what
you define self care to be
and how it fits into acceptance?
HAEMIN SUNIM: Yeah
I talk about this
in my first chapter of this book
because while I was growing up,
I was taught to be a good boy.
I just wanted to make my
parents very happy and proud,
and I wanted to be
a good student, too.
So I wanted to make my
teacher to be happy and proud,
and then I want to
be a good friends.
I wanted to make my friends
to be happy around me,
so I wanted to
please other people.
However, while I was doing
it, I neglected myself.
I neglected the
well-being of myself.
For example, when I
went to graduate school,
I remember because I would say
yes, yes, yes to everything.
And in the group
work, I ended up
getting all the difficult
work all the time.
So I was just assumed that
if I do one difficult work,
maybe the other will do
difficult work later,
but it didn't happen like
that, especially in the US.
So I said, oh, I don't know
what to do with this problem.
So I was talking to
my friend, and then he
told me that you
have an obligation
to be good to yourself first.
So when we are being--
taking time to care
about self, care about
are physical or emotional
well-being, then what happen
is when we are happier,
when we are healthier,
then we can be nice
to other people.
And the opposite is also true.
If we just say yes, yes, yes
to everything and if you've
become overwhelmed and you
become completely exhausted,
then your relationship
will suffer.
So I think we have to learn
to say no to some time
to certain thing but do it
in a very compassionate way
and so that you are not
creating abrupt difficulty
in a relationship.
SHIFALI MUDUMBA: I'd like
to shift gears a little bit
and talk about depression.
Approximately 1 in
4 people in the UK
will experience a mental
health problem each year,
and 1 in 6 report experiencing
a common mental health
problem in any given week.
There is a chapter on
depression in the book,
so seems like a big challenge.
How should we handle
it, and how should we
react to it when perhaps
we're feeling depressed?
HAEMIN SUNIM: Yeah,
it's a big top topic.
And sometimes we know the
cause of our own depression,
but sometimes we simply do
not know why we feel that way.
Maybe because our body
is getting old, and then
to a certain change in our body,
we feel emotionally depressed.
But sometimes we do know
why we feel depressed.
For example, if you
have a very high hope,
you have a high expectation
high goal to achieve,
but if you look at your own
reality you are way down here.
And so the distance
between where you are
and where you want
to go it's huge.
And you've been
trying to go there
very for many, many
years, and yet you
realize that I may not
be able to get there.
And then you, of course,
feel very depressed.
If that is the case, then rather
than setting really high bar,
I would recommend that why
don't you break it down
and then to look for something
easier goal to achieve.
And so rather than feeling
that I am a huge failure, I--
you can turn it around
and say I do make--
my life is full of success.
It can be very little
thing, but it can be--
you can do it little by little.
And you can also--
if you're seriously
depressed, then I
think it is important
that you look and seek
out professional
help from a doctor.
But if you are feeling a little
bit blue once in a while,
then I think it is important
that we move our body.
We often think that we
can if by just thinking
about positive thing, maybe
we can change our mind,
but our mind and body is so
close really interconnected.
So if you're feeling
a little bit depressed
or a little bit
blue, then I suggest
that why don't you
go out and take
a walk in a beautiful nature.
And so if you look at a bird
or flowers or green lawn
or whatever then a
sky, you can get out
of this perpetual
negative thinking loop.
You know what I mean?
So by paying attention to what
is happening in front of you,
you can become
less self obsessed.
SHIFALI MUDUMBA:
I'd like to know
how many people in the
room meditate, say, daily?
Sometimes.
OK.
At least once a month?
So we have some
enthusiasts in the room.
I'd like to, if I
may, read a passage
from the book about meditation.
"The true nature of our
mind is like the sky.
Our thoughts are like clouds,
our emotions like lightning,
and the sky accepts
them all equally,
watching as they shift
and move across it.
The weather of
thoughts and emotions
rises and passes away, but
the sky remains the same--
clear, luminous, open."
It's a really wonderful
passage, but it's
hard to get into that
state where it really
feels like the clouds
and the lightning are
moving in and out.
And what-- how do we get there?
I guess it's-- obviously there's
an element of regular practice.
But what advice do you have
for us meditation enthusiasts?
HAEMIN SUNIM: Very good.
Very good.
I was deeply touched
and very happy
that you guys are
into meditation.
That is really wonderful.
But I was-- I'm also hoping that
you guys can take a step more
and do a little bit
deeper meditation.
That is we can meditate just
to feel good about ourselves,
to understand about our thinking
mind and things like that.
But you can also
go a step further.
That is what is
that which knows.
We know everything.
Do you-- are you
aware that I am here.
So then what is that which is
aware of Haemin Sunim is here?
You see what I mean?
Yeah.
We only pay attention
to the object,
the object of awareness, but can
we pay attention to awareness
itself?
Can you become aware
of your own awareness.
From that awareness-- field
of awareness I would say--
everything rises and disappears.
It can be your good feeling
or negative thoughts,
whatever that is.
It arises and disappears.
However, this awareness
field, it never moves.
It never disappears.
Can you stop being aware?
Can you try-- let's say
for the next 3 minute--
can you say for the next
three minutes, I will--
I have decided not to be aware?
Can you do that?
Even if you close your
eyes and close your ears,
you will become aware that,
oh, I don't see anything.
You've become aware that,
oh, there is nothing.
Awareness is still happening--
you see what I mean--
whether you like it or not.
But the-- whatever the
object you become aware of,
it comes and goes.
It's impermanent.
However, that which
is aware, it stays.
That is a deeper meditation.
SHIFALI MUDUMBA:
How do we get there?
HAEMIN SUNIM: The truth
is we are already there.
We just have to simply
see what is already there.
We don't try to be aware.
When you look at
me, do you try, say,
OK, I'm going to try
to be aware of what
is happening in front of me?
No, it just happen
automatically.
So it is already
there, this awareness.
It follows everywhere.
Even when you are in a
dreaming, you are aware.
This awareness you can
never escape so to speak.
But do you have any memory
of this awareness being born?
Do you have any memory of the
birth of you or your awareness?
No, we don't.
Awareness is ever present.
It was never born, and
therefore it will never die.
SHIFALI MUDUMBA: But you
have to tune into it somehow.
And that's attention?
HAEMIN SUNIM: Yeah,
just to become aware
of your own awareness.
SHIFALI MUDUMBA:
How much of that
is, for example, paying
attention to your breathing
because I find that
meditation practice,
it starts with the
simplest way of becoming
aware is being aware of
your breath because it's
a way of bringing
your mind back.
HAEMIN SUNIM: Exactly.
It's an excellent practice.
If we can just bring
our mind to the--
our breath, it has
so many benefits.
First thing is our
body feels better.
As we are taking a deep
breath, what happened?
We feel much more relaxed,
our heart starts to slow down,
and we feel a different part of
our mind becomes more relaxed
and has space.
And also as we breathe--
pay attention to our breath,
we are bringing our mind
into the present moment.
When we bring our mind
to the present moment,
there is no more
attachment to what
happened in the past, no
more anxiety about what's
going to happen in the future.
Also when your mind
becomes empty and quiet,
that's where the
creativity comes.
If you want to be creative,
notice that usually you
have this creative idea when
you are not constantly thinking.
You might be thinking a
lot and then give yourself
some one hour of rest time
while you're walking around
in a park or something or
taking a shower, and then
all of a sudden, what happens?
Boom!
I have a new idea.
So when we do not have
a lot of thoughts,
when our mind become very
quiet, we have this creativity.
Another benefit
is when the breath
itself does not have any form--
breath doesn't have any form--
can you capture any
form of a breath?
No because it's formless
because we are paying attention
to what is formless, which
is very close to awareness.
Awareness does not
have any form or shape.
So it is very good entry
point to become aware
of your awareness.
SHIFALI MUDUMBA:
With that, I would
like to hand it over to
Googlers to ask some questions.
AUDIENCE: Hey, thank
you for being here.
I just wanted to ask because
obviously the scenarios
that you are touching on--
cancer, losing a child,
something like that--
what if that is the
present and that's--
we're focusing on the present
but the present sucks?
I agree with letting
go of the past
and not looking to
the future, but I
think it's harder to do if
there's actually something
going on in the present that
doesn't deserve focus maybe
or drags us down.
What do we do?
HAEMIN SUNIM: Right.
Right.
First of all, my
heart goes out to you.
You'll be in a very difficult
situation, especially when
your child is sick.
It's a really daunting thing.
Or you yourself has
some kind of illness.
What I would say is this.
If you are carefully examine
your body or examine your mind,
you will notice that you
are not sick 24 hours.
You know what I mean?
Even if you are sick, even
if you have an illness,
you are not sick 24 hours a day.
But what's troubling
you is whenever
you have a thought
of illness, whenever
gosh I have an illness.
I don't know what to do.
Then that thought
triggers this depression
or depressive emotions.
So realize that when
you are little bit
in a difficult
situation, maybe it
is the thought that keep
thinking about it again
and again that is
causing the problem.
What-- but sometimes
we do forget,
and then we watch TV and watch
some funny episode of sitcom
or something then we can
laugh because our mind is not
dwelling on that thought.
So as the thought we momentarily
not dwelling on, then we
don't--
we can appreciate what is
happening in spite of this.
For example, I remember I
was in a difficult situation
where I had a fan in
Korea who really liked me
obsessively and tried to
follow me around and show up
on every single talk that I was
giving, and I was a little bit
scared.
This person was
almost stalker right.
Whenever I thought about her,
I was feeling a little bit
depressed because this
person is projecting
a lot of this person's
emotion onto me.
And if I do not tell--
or satisfied this person's
needs, then this person
goes online and ended up
saying all the negative things
about me and then
making people believe
this person's testimony.
But whenever I was
thinking about her,
I realized that my mind
became very depressed.
However, when I was
not thinking about her,
I realized that I was OK.
So the very source of suffering
was a thought I realized.
What is making us feel
really depressed and angry
is whether we dwell
on that thought.
So if we can just bring our
mind to present moment, what
is really happening
right in front of us,
you can have a cup of
tea with your best friend
or you can be listening
to inspiring talk,
then you don't have to think
about those kind of problems.
You see what I mean.
So I would say that
pay more attention
to present moment even more.
SHIFALI MUDUMBA: More questions?
AUDIENCE: I have a
question on whether you
have any suggestions--
I know you've talked a lot
about individual practice
to be more present
and more aware.
As a family with children
and with your partner,
is there any practices
that you think
could help as a family--
the whole family?
HAEMIN SUNIM: When you are
living with many children
then you have a
very demanding job
and when you go back you have
a partner waiting for you,
then it's very difficult for
us to have a sense of calmness
in everyday activity.
So what I usually suggest is
see if you can still carve out
a little bit of time even
if it's five minutes a day
or 10 minutes a day.
So what that means is
rather than getting off
at your regular bus stations,
you can get off like a three
stop before, and
then you can maybe
enjoy you know walking
back home while listening
to your favorite song.
So carving out-- just having
this intention to care about
myself first, you can go to
your favorite coffee shop
and while you are
enjoying coffee or tea,
you can have a more
relaxed time and checking
in with my mind and my body.
Or you can go to your
favorite bookshop.
Whenever I go to bookshop
and see a empty chair,
I'm so happy.
I go sit there and read, and
this gives me a downtime.
And then when I go to--
back to your home or
go back to your work,
then you can go back
with your refreshed mind.
And also in your daily activity
with your family member, what
I would suggest is rather
than thinking that we already
know about our family
member, we often
think that I already
know everything
there is to know about my
boyfriend, girlfriend, husband,
and wife or my children,
then what happen
is we stop asking questions.
We are not curious about
what happened to their lives.
But the thing is
we always change.
We are changing.
Our children are changing.
Our husband or
partners are changing.
So if we approach to your family
member with sense of curiosity
and humility that you don't know
everything there is to know,
then you can have a
deeper conversation.
You can ask, oh, how
have you been today?
How was-- what is going on?
And then it is also important
to share not just the fact.
People often just say, oh what
time are you getting home?
Oh, 7:00.
What did you have dinner?
I had chicken teriyaki.
That's like a fact.
You just asked.
However, I think it is
important that we also
ask how we are feeling,
which is the deeper self.
How are you feeling?
So allowing some time for
us to unpack our own feeling
and feeling that the other
person is really hearing me
out, it can create deeper bond.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
Thank you for being here today.
There's a situation that I
find puzzling in general,
which is on one hand the--
I buy into the power
of vulnerability,
the importance of
embracing imperfections,
of knowing them, et cetera.
But on the other hand,
I have the feeling
that the world and
especially social media world
can be a great
medium for knowledge,
et cetera, there is this
race towards perfection
and only actually
depicting what's perfect.
When you look at people
today on social media,
no one really puts their picture
when they're feeling ill or bad
or when they're arguing
with their partner.
It's all like how
happy, clappy, peppy.
And I find it really puzzling
because I think it's antinomic.
What would be your
advice to maybe,
especially the
younger ones that are
going to experience more and
more social pressure on media
and to still keep that
philosophy of loving
imperfections?
Thank you.
HAEMIN SUNIM: I was in
Canada near Vancouver.
I was invited to
give a talk there.
And then after the event,
I drove up with my friend,
and I heard there's
a beautiful mountain.
And if you just walk
about four hours,
and you'll see snow-capped
mountain with beautiful lake.
So I decided to go there.
So I went there,
but what I did not
know was that while
climbing up going up,
up up, there were
a lot of flies.
You know the box flies?
And so for the last four hours,
as I was growing up, I would--
I have to do this.
I have to do this constantly
because there are so
many flies and bugs around me.
And then once I get to that
in a beautiful scenic spot,
I was very happy,
but at the same time
I was extremely
hungry and exhausted.
However, when I
took the photo, I
was smiling as if
you know there was
no bug, as if there was
no exhaustion, as if there
was no hunger.
So when you see very happy face
on your friend's Facebook entry
or Twitter or
other social media,
Instagram or YouTube,
just remind yourself
that maybe this person
was fighting off
the flies for the
last four hours
and then suffering from
the exhaustion and hunger.
So I think having that
awareness helps quite a bit.
And also rather than
comparing ourselves
with somebody who's doing
a lot better because there
will be always somebody who is
always doing better than you--
I was advised--
I remember we have to compare
ourselves to our old us.
So, for example, I remember
in Korea, the richest person
in Korea is the owner of Samsung
you know the Samsung right?
And so I thought that, wow,
this guy must be really rich.
And then one day I was
reading a newspaper article,
and it ranked the wealth of
different people in the world.
And he ranked like
170-something.
And then I realized that even
if he was to comparing himself,
then he would feel, oh, gosh,
I only made it 170-something.
You see what I mean?
So we shouldn't do that.
Rather we should become proud
of how much we have achieved
so far for the last
10 years or 15 years,
how much we have grown
spiritually, emotionally,
and also career-wise.
SHIFALI MUDUMBA: I think
we'll take one last question.
AUDIENCE: Right here.
SHIFALI MUDUMBA: Oh, sorry.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I think we can learn
a lot definitely and apply
a lot to our lives.
I am just thinking if we take
this idea of being content
and being constantly
present in our--
to the extreme and let's say
everyone became like a Buddhist
monk or close to that,
what would happen?
Because a lot of the stuff that
we do is because the problems
we have, the things
that bugs us,
the ambitions and
insecurities that drives us.
So how do you view being
content with ourselves
and really enjoying the
life versus our obligation
towards society or
civilization to progress it
by constantly seeing the bugs
and trying to get rid of them
or put them aside or make
them not bite you right
rather than being content
that they are around you
and just ignoring them?
HAEMIN SUNIM: Like connecting
to the present moment
and being mindful
of what's going on,
it doesn't mean that
you become lazy.
It doesn't become-- it
doesn't mean that you become
I don't care about the world.
I think just being
content actually
allows us to engage in our
work in a much proficient way.
When you are happy, notice
that you can actually
respond quickly.
There is a space for you
to tolerate annoyances
of other people because you find
much more peaceful at heart.
The opposite is the problem.
That is if your heart is closed
off and feeling that you're
completely isolated
and you are thinking
about what happened in the past
while ignoring the bug that
is coming up right now, then I
think this can become problems.
Your stress level is already
up and feeling like a victim
because I have another
wok that I have to do.
So I would say that
just being mindful
doesn't mean that you
become like a corpse.
Instead you can actually respond
much more compassionately,
much quickly to the demands
or difficulty of other peoples
having.
SHIFALI MUDUMBA: One last
question in the back, Dennis.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you for being here.
So we have a mindfulness
meditation community here
at Google.
And there's a lot
of people who are
I think trying to get
into a daily practice.
I'm really curious
to hear what is
your take on the benefits
of a daily practice
and also maybe
some practical tips
around how to
establish one because I
think it's quite hard
in the beginning.
It takes a while
to get the benefits
or to start feeling the impact.
So if you've any tips on how to
best get into that a routine.
HAEMIN SUNIM: Right.
Right.
Well, I would say
that if you are
interested in
mindfulness meditation
and you want to
get into that but I
don't know how to do that, then
the first thing I would say
is make a--
have a very low expectation.
So rather than
say, oh, I'm going
to sit quietly for the next 20
minutes without any thinking
and then paying attention fully
to my breath, just reduce.
Scale back and say
that well I'm going
to spend next two minutes.
See if we can--
if I can just sit quietly
and enjoy my breath.
And if you accomplish two
minutes, then you can say,
oh, I will do 2
minutes and 30 seconds,
and then slowly you
can increase it.
So you don't have to say I'm
going to somehow bliss out.
And if I'm not, then
maybe I'm a failure.
But that is not the case.
Meditation isn't so much to get
to a certain state of our mind,
rather whether we can mindful
of whatever the state we are in.
So if we can be
mindful of, oh, I
feel frustrated because
nothing is happening
or I feel wasting of my time
because I'm not focusing,
then become mindful
of that thought.
Oh, I just had that
frustration thought.
Oh, interesting.
You know what I mean?
Oh, I had that
frustration feeling.
Interesting.
This is mindfulness.
So I would-- that
would be my answer.
SHIFALI MUDUMBA: Thank you.
So I should say
[SPEAKING  NON-ENGLISH LANGUAGE]
HAEMIN SUNIM: Yes.
[SPEAKING NON-ENGLISH LANGUAGE]
SHIFALI MUDUMBA: Thanks so
much, everyone, for joining.
And please join me
in thanking Haemin--
sorry-- for a really
wonderful session.
Thank you so much.
HAEMIN SUNIM: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]